now it's been a really big week hasn't
it the uk government has set out its net
zero strategies said to be the most
comprehensive plan of any major
industrialized country and with just
days before the global gaze fixes firmly
on glasgow for cop26 is the strategy a
good example to the world i'm going to
speak to you first mohammed on this it
took a long time to get this document
didn't it we kept waiting it's a big fat
document outlining the government's plan
is it worth the paper it's written on
i don't think so and i don't think
anyone
really wants to see a far-off net zero
pledge
that will supposedly balance the uk's
emissions budget by mid-century and by
using tools including unproven you know
techno fixes i think what we want is
what we want to see is actually what the
uk is going to do today
tomorrow and every year to come
to eliminate its major sources of
emissions including its continued fossil
fuel production and use to be able to
address the current climate emergency we
need real plans real solutions real
finance and real zero for an agent just
transition
so clearly you don't think that that
isn't
clearly you don't think that's what this
document represents and what about you
jen i mean the uk government likes to
think of itself as a world leader here
in its climate pledge pledges is that
delusional
well you're right it's been a bit a big
week i think about a dozen or more
policies were put out the last day
totaling over 1800 pages so
we're all a bit in digestion mode right
now and trying to figure out what it all
means
it's definitely better than where we
were and it's definitely
puts the uk uh in good stead when we
compare it to other countries
it's not enough to get us to net zero
and
there's still some policies in there
missing especially around investment
but we do have to admit this is a
serious piece of work that looks across
the government in all of the departments
and looks at what they can do and what
their targets should be
so
it's better than where we were and it's
a good step forward it's just not quite
enough yet
and mohammed the key to all of this
isn't it is credibility because if
government policy is credible then you
get private investment at pouring in and
then you can encourage individuals to
change their behavior and how far away
do you think the government is from
being credible on climate
i think they've included some good stuff
so the strategy of course includes
investment in expanding electric
vehicles something i think we should
celebrate and and welcome they start on
offshore wind they start them you know
the creation of bring hydrogen you know
all these things are important but what
you know the challenge that we will face
is actually whether we can be able to
even mobilize the funding that is
required to be able to implement this
strategy i think this strategy is still
seriously unfunded it doesn't get us to
zero
it doesn't get us to zero within the
time frame that will allow us to hold
global warming to below 1.5
and it needs the support of tertiary if
it's going to be effective i think what
is going to help us is if we if we can
actually mobilize the work government
behind the strategy and be able to
revise this strategy so that it gets us
to real zero
within a time frame that we can actually
hold global women to below 1.5 and so
without funds uh without funds that will
actually allow this strategy to be
delivered i don't think it will live up
to the hype so the government is
actually in danger of acting and
promising us grand you know promises
but not delivering and i think if it
does that right i think it will inspire
the rest of the world and we'll see a
race to the top
and jen some of the sectors that
mohammed was mentioning there that are
high points that the government's
focused on are already profitable aren't
they how does the government go about
encouraging money into technologies
which are still quite experimental not
yet profitable
that's the big question so there's a
role for government to play in terms of
providing initial investment there's
also a role for government to play in
terms of an investment bank or a way to
sort of nurture those technologies until
they're commercially viable
there is a huge piece of this missing
which is how are they going to mobilize
private investment into this so as
muhammad has said it's underfunded right
now we don't know where all this money
is coming from there's sort of an idea
that the private sector is going to help
out
but without a strategy to mobilize that
private finance
we're not sure how we're going to hit
most of these targets or fulfill a lot
of these promises in the net zero plan
you